hey you're on uh that Mexican OTS album
you gotta get out on your shoes you know
we made that song two years ago you guys
are both in my opinion like two of the
best rappers
also both of you have an affinity for
being naked uh I mean he he's a
shirtless [__] as well a little couple
of shirtless guys you know I think you
guys should do we've never been
Shameless together not yet
I might keep my shirt on there
I was gonna say this feels like a
perfect moment for y'all to do like
collab project together a little eight
piece little seven pieces
and neither of you should have shirts on
in the cover yeah like you got like a
Luchador mask on and I have like a
cowboy hat on you guys both have cowboys
hat on you got both no shirts man I mean
I feel like that would be like this
equivalent to like Nas and Jay-Z coming
together like 98 and doing it all
together man that'd be historical yeah
like crazy